I'm hungry good for you
and this is sibling right
ten mrs. Beck in The Hunger Games
Catching Fire the sequel to the big
blockbuster hit several years ago and
what do we think of it loved it hated it
really no actually yeah it's good um the
funny thing about this movie is that it
is a big retread of the first film
you've got Katniss being submit again to
The Hunger Games and a lot to say uh
Peeta is back in The Hunger Games they
have to go they had to survive they have
to find strategies they have to play
celebrities once again so you would
think that this movie would be really
tired and really sucky but they throw in
so many good twists and turns and new
characters and the ending actually does
evolve and monkeys I don't know where
the monkeys were not very good but but
but the ending does in fact evolved to a
sequel that you really really want to
see um for me what I really liked about
it is that because it is such a retread
that they had to go back what they do in
this one I thought was clever was that
it's them dealing with the celebrity of
after being going through the famous
event and I think that is a real issue
because there's so many people I you
know where child stars or big actors
that do something and they have that
celebrity but that wasn't mean after
that the celebrity ever really wanted to
lie about keeping up appearances well
that's where it gets even better because
here the celebrity is actually a matter
of life and death which is always so
stupid but at the same time I think any
politician I yelped
for that yeah well in lying lying and
keeping up good PR is any celebrities
way to survive you know and basically
keep themselves in good standing with
the public let's be honest here but yeah
in this case it literally does me like
Andy yeah and and what's good about two
is that they deal with how how much you
have to sacrifice to that celebrity and
how much you want to keep your humanity
you have Katniss trying to be kind to
you know her fellow people and you know
breaking character is saying that
don't know this is a tragedy oh and we
will survive and we will be strong and
that's not keeping up well with the
people who are in charge and that's
getting him angry
so it's her battling what what she can
do with the celebrity what she can't do
the total power she has and the total
lack of power she has and her real
inability to keep up the appearance
which really ties in surprisingly really
smartly uh because you don't think you
just think oh come on she can do this
better or can't or when they have the
twist and there was the point of this
twist but they do actually tie in and
we'll go more into them the the spoiler
corner um so yeah I like even though
what's going back in The Hunger Games it
doesn't it feels like it doesn't happen
till halfway through we're in the first
one I think like maybe the end of the
first act it happened um so I like that
they died so much into the celebrity
into how harsh it is and fix a lot of
prompts with the first one I can see
things yes
tripods steadicams invest like they add
oh my god you know what
shaky cam has done more in my lifetime
to ruin film as I know it probably even
more than CGI now I feel like it's just
like it is the it literally is the
crutch of the heck director now every
time I see shakey cam now sometimes it's
used effectively but a lot of times that
Man of Steel is a great example the
first Hunger Games the shaky cam and
that I lame is was a mixed bag I thought
it was overused there is just like
whenever I see it now I'm just like oh
come on it is such a cliche it's like I
want to give you a sense of immediacy
mmm yeah you know my first for whatever
reason shaky cam doesn't bother me as
much particularly in action see and and
in the first Hunger Games you know they
obviously want to get the pg-13 rating
which I don't know if it's a young adult
book so it kind of makes sense so you
have to when little kids in the first
film are getting slaughtered yeah I
understand it I got that no slugs we're
dressed
the rest yes that was ridiculous yeah
they don't dad same thing like Man of
Steel the introduction to that where it
should you're just looking at like memos
mmmm Bowles the members of the
Kryptonian Council there and it's like
blurry and there's no point
it's literally it is a cheap cheap tool
the first Hunger Games is because you
don't know how to basically let your
cinematographer do their darn so uh so I
mean apart from that it seems like a lot
of problems with the first one are made
better here and you read the second book
and you were saying you weren't really
looking forward to the movie cuz no not
I and the reviews like I normally I try
not to really read too much into reviews
so I was looking up the reviews cuz I
really didn't want to see this um the
second book was my least favorite for
all the reasons you had mentioned it
just is the same thing over again it's a
retread they go into the Hunger Games
again um it was not a bad book but it's
the one that I had remembered the least
it's the Chamber of Secrets yeah it is
the chamber of secrets of the series it
is just like I kind of just did all that
stuff again and you don't really
remember what happened and you know and
particularly with sending her back in
The Hunger Games in the book I was
skipping pages left because I'm just
like bending there done that seen this
this was the whole first book so that's
why I was blown away when I loved this
movie cuz I'm why I Wow
this was my least favorite of the books
but I love this movie so much better
than the first one
and it's because it fixed a lot of the
problems in the book the love trying on
the book is not particularly strong just
stop with love triangles writers unless
you really know how to do a love to it
you know come here we're gonna have a
moment unless you really know how to do
a love triangle right just don't do it
don't don't don't
it's okay you can have two people in
love you can have like two people in
love and have another like bestfriend
there's other than even handsome it's
other elements of drama of it you can do
it don't don't do it but love I don't
think writers understand is actually an
interesting thing
just between two people yeah is it the
third one in real life real life getting
in the middle of it yeah it's it's okay
fat you can you give it like that and
you can make it interesting cuz it's
pretty interesting in real life too so
just just just let's yeah enough with
the love drink love triangle you had a
good run mate have to enter the irony is
that I do mind it that much no that's
because in the book the love triangle
was more prominent to end in this movie
it's not I swear to god it's like they
were just like and she likes Gail Gail
gets whipped ever done I I will say this
that the chemistry between her and the
Gail character is totally non-existent
yeah there is something seen I think
well so little on it and they you don't
care yeah point is sort of us I think
you do sort of go well yeah we know and
I'm sure there's probably some team Gail
team Peeta Griff out there's read the
book I think is fair like Gail I was
like who cares yeah it's like nobody did
we know where this story is going yeah
so wanted reading the book where I think
Susan Collins tried to throw in a red
herring you hear there to make you
wonder I still knew where this story was
going so the less love triangle the
better The Hunger Games portion I swear
was cut back in the movie here if it
feels like it was but for so much better
for that because I hated The Hunger
Games portion I should say hate hated
there's no Boris yeah I thought there
was some twist they threw the book that
we're good the mockingjays were really
really good there's like a poison gas
it's good that the monkey sucked the the
idea of the clock I think is interesting
yeah but I mean we won't go too much
yeah but just was it just was a lot of
filler and there are some interesting
twists there but the movie rushes
through them to its advantage and
because it's not the interesting part
because we've been there done that and
the interesting part of the book for me
was the whole first half of that book is
what I remembered and what I really
liked it was like okay so now you have
to strategize but the
is different and the whole playing up
her character is now revolutionary and
the people that helped her out doing
that and the whole thing like Haymitch
is involved is like well promise me that
you'll let PETA survive and then yeah
like that's what they do is I don't want
to go and the drama and and the the best
scene in the book though was that first
scene where she walks in and president
snow was there and if you read it in the
book it's chilling just creepy and
donald sutherland and the way they shot
it was so perfect like I literally was
just getting goosebumps it's like he
will Santa Claus no and the fact I could
get those same chills that I did reading
the book fantastic Direction fantastic
acting yeah Jennifer Lawrence a Donald
something within that scene so perfect
and also also vote from I'm forgetting
his name I apologize but Bridge to
Terabithia boy um he you know I was
really uncomfortable yes I'm a few other
movies I said this is a good child actor
even Wayans in crap he is good and I
hope he goes on to something is going on
to this and I think it's a good role for
him because this one in the next one I
think are gonna give him real props the
first one does not do much justice to
him and I got him okay and I've read the
book but I found him very likeable and
interesting in the fridge I finally
likable on interesting there's not much
for his character to chew on this one
there's more for him to chew on as an
heir as far as the plot I think yeah I
think so much that is the acting cuz
this so easily could have been a bland
forgettable you know he could have been
Gael number two you know but instead
they make him so interesting and so much
of that is his acting and I think he's
really talented I'm glad he's gone to
this uh I get a general Lawrence again
just uh oh really nails it and you're
just so interested what she's doing and
it's not something along the lines of
you know oh come on why doesn't she just
do that this is obvious don't just play
the game or whatever you they show so
well why it's so hard for anyone to do
and let's think let's think about like
cuz I loved all of her work and I really
really
Jennifer Lawrence as an actor and a
person and you know for all of the great
work she's done and silver linings
playbook and let's think really hard
about what this role requires you're a
person who has just killed people gun
out of it alive is now a celebrity
possibly revolutionary now has been
asked by the President to basically to
spare the your family and lives of the
person you really like to lie to pretend
that you're in love with this other kid
to run around and make these speeches
you know where you're totally supporting
the regime while at the same time you
have to portray the fact that deep down
inside you hate this regime that you're
just reading it off a cue card but you
have to just convince it just enough
because you're also trying to protect
your own there are like 14 different
things going on in this one role well
and what I find so interesting and I
think I bring us up in the bum review to
it which in a way and that this is just
pure sort of fun comparison is that
Jeffrey Lawrence herself and people I
mean this girl is literally on fire and
you know and she's this hot celebrity
and part of the reason is that she is so
likable and she does not for the most
part do that typical Hollywood
where she seems very generous sure yeah
she seems very genuine which is like
it's so funny watching this movie where
she has to play this stuff and she
doesn't understand why and she's just
trying to do good things and you all see
that going on in real life as well in a
very different way but you see it going
on and I'm wondering if that reflects in
the role of the scenes it could be I
mean the scenes where she's reading the
pre rehearsed speeches are my favorite
because you can see it in her face like
14 different emotions of just like I
hate reading this crap I have to read
this family at the same time she's
looking down at this crowd going
I'm sorry for you I feel for you this
isn't the real me but I have to convince
the president this is the real media
it's like what Li Gracie is what the
sort of role that could drive a person
insane trying to portray what I like
about the way they look at celebrity in
this as well even though of course is
pushed to an extreme is that so often I
get a TMZ and all that so often
stuff is going on behind the scenes with
celebrities politics all this stuff so
much is going behind the scenes and the
average viewer watching - oh well I know
it's going oh well the surface that's
exactly what it is and so often it's not
and this shows so well just the damaging
you know it just what terrible things
can happen if you just rely on only what
you see in the celebrity and you know
everything and so often you don't this
is where both the film in the book
really really succeeds it succeeds as a
commentary on the cult of celebrity and
on our need as a people both on a
political level and for entertainment
that need to just partake in that cult
hmm you know the politics need it to
distract the people it's really about
the cult of distraction this entire
series the whole way through the cult of
distraction and how it's used by evil
people to manipulate the masses TMZ you
know and also about how some people the
capital in particular gets sucked into
it and how it affects the rest of us how
many poor people are out there who want
to be a celebrity how many people have
risen from the ranks from poverty to
become a celebrity only to die of a drug
overdose or something because it ends up
just messing them up you know this
series more than anything is I think
more about that and that's where the
book succeeds and that's where the film
succeeds when it gets to the Hunger
Games part yeah that's actually the
weakest gives a you know you feel
like you have to have that for you know
for the action for the younger crowd for
the people that want the violence but I
like that it's it's not entirely
glorified by all the very news Leah but
you all but your what I like is that
rather than getting into it because it's
violent you get into it because you want
to see people you like get through it
which is YV lack of violence doesn't
bother me because it's not about that
yeah um
third book gets a little more into that
but to me it's always been more about
the cult of celebrity so the Hunger
Games is almost like the tool that I
think the author is using to sort of get
into that there's not to say there isn't
stuff about violence and war and
revolutions as well but you know to me
it's still focused it still even works
in and around that because it's
obviously they're building her up as you
know she's going to be a revolutionary
so and and it's not a few times where
there's a the ending is definitely it to
be continued but it's it's a very
welcome to be continued and I'm actually
seeing it Y saw the first Hunger Games
on okay maybe I can see the second one
that comes out whatever it's like at the
end of this one like I can't wait to see
the third one you keep dying oh my god
yeah keep lighting I cannot wait to see
what's gonna happen in this story it
ends on such a perfect note and I
remember when we were watching it we're
both are like and cut and cut any
consequence just realize moments and it
has this perfect symbol to show to get
you just jacked up for the next one
you're just like always my test of
a truly good movie my Testament really
truly well directed film is what it cuts
if you can predict the moment it's gonna
cut in a good way like you're just like
n cut cuz this is just too perfect drama
yeah like my hockey uh you know um a
fire strikes bad a fire strikes back
Godfather got it you know you look at
those moves in a second cut and it does
it's like perfect and this did the same
thing I was just watching I was like and
cut and within three seconds was like
boom and I was like oh yeah no it's it
so we really enjoy rising Lea well-made
for yeah uh uh we're really surprised me
too so um yeah I guess the only thing I
could think and you could probably hear
from us talking is that if you if you
haven't read the books and you're
looking for something completely
different there is definitely creature
than there but I would definitely argue
that the twists and turns and the
characters good characters are this much
more interesting than the first one
Elizabeth Banks even as the woman it's
like getting drawn into a - it
even in her own way like she's an
interesting there you know I think of it
as a reboot yeah watch does not watch is
like you know what we're sorry for part
one here's a reboot like what I thought
while I probe into but they were there
was some mistakes is like you know what
probably isn't perfect you know it take
to Wednesday to its rebooted here we go
if you look at it kind of like that I
think it actually works much better cuz
yeah it does get redundant but so yeah I
we greatly enjoyed it so that's yeah I
think the best thing I can say is um I
think Harv Bennett was talking about the
Star Trek films and how Star Trek one
was a bomb the slow motion picture and I
think he was saying he knew that way it
wasn't a bomb it was a critical buy it
was a critical time yeah the film did
well enough cuz of a Star Trek but it
was a critical bomb and they were
looking to fix it so when Wrath of Khan
came out he was reading the reviews he's
like I knew we had hit it when the
critics were saying now that's more like
it
and that's really the best thing I can
say this is more like it
you know they nailed it this time I hope
it carries over into three because I
yeah I gotta do it gets me excited for
the third one so and that's exactly what
this movie is supposed to do and it's
just a good flick so that's all we got
man they will see it stay hungry for
Thanksgiving is it you know it is
interesting that they released hunger
games on Thanksgiving in then oh it's
good point this book's Oh